I have lupus have type 1 diabetes I have
Hashimoto's I have ankylosing
spondylitis and Crohn's disease one day
it was December 19th like I'll never
forget it and I just woke up and my
right foot was really swollen
honestly throughout my life I've had
like health issues I've had periods
where my body is just shut down and I
couldn't move I got rashes throughout my
entire adolescence and I just thought
that was just me and I just thought it
was stress-related I remember just going
through one of the most stressful
semesters I've had in college and I was
feeling really manic like I thought I
was going through like an episode
because for a few months I would feel
like really good and a lot of energy and
just like racing thoughts and it was
like kind of jittery and I was losing
weight and I felt like oh that's great
and then I would be eating the same food
and a few months later I would really
like tired and I feel really emotional
and really depressed and I'd be gaining
weight and I didn't really change
anything in my lifestyle mom took me to
Urgent Care and they did an x-ray and
they said I had a hairline fracture so
this day like I don't think I did but I
don't really know so they gave me like
this little butt booty thing to walk
around and you're supposed to wear it
for like a few weeks and after those few
weeks nothing had changed and it had
actually kind of gotten worse my foot
was more swollen and now my big toe was
also really swollen in her and I was
kind of just like the beginning of a six
month process of going to dozens of
doctors and getting like so many
different diagnoses oh by the time I was
in college I was getting sick a ton and
after I had graduated I went through a
period where I just could not move my
body it literally felt like I had been
run over by a train multiple times
people would be like well what's feeling
bad and I'm like everything only signs
or symptoms that I was getting where I
was just thirsty a lot like all the time
like I just needed a lot of fluids and
so by extension I was just like peeing a
lot and I went to the doctor and they
thought oh were you feel like you're
depressed or maybe gonna give you some
pills cuz I just didn't I was crying in
the doctor's office I was crying over
what I did my physical and my results
came back and my thyroid was all off a
doctor told my mom that I had leukemia
while I was in the room and just like so
many other random diagnoses until
finally my mom took me to a
Rheumatologist who diagnosed me at the
time with juvenile rheumatoid arthritis
it wasn't until my mom told me that
lupus actually runs in my family and I
should get tested for it I had been to
doctors they never seemed to test
autoimmune diseases first so I had to
literally beg them please just like run
some tests for it for a few years I
thought okay I'm just like living with
this arthritis thing and then my
freshman year of high school I started
having lots of stomach issues they had a
colonoscopy and I was diagnosed with
colitis it was only until like I went on
vacation after the semester ended with
my family and stuff and my mom actually
started noticing those like signs of
just being thirsty all the time and she
was just like you should check to see if
you have that type of never you went to
like school doctor after that and they
did some tests for her levels and stuff
urine and everything they were saying
yeah this is like signs of type 1
diabetes having the colitis the juvenile
rheumatoid arthritis and the iritis my
doctor was like oh actually because of
all of these different things we're
gonna test you for something called the
HLA b27 gene and they tested me for that
and I had it and that's when they sort
of changed my diagnosis staying closing
spondylitis I did my physical and my
results came back and my I read was all
off they started giving me more thyroid
and you find out that you like have
something wrong with you when you feel
like something's wrong it just makes you
feel so much better because it just
confirms like nothing's were actually
wrong with you just like your body is
messing up I'm not a super emotional
person but when I got my diagnosis I
cried half out of relief that I knew
like something was wrong with me and 1/2
out of I don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on people don't really talk about
autoimmune diseases so like I didn't
really know much about it imagine we
were living in a world already of like
driverless cars and that's like been
your whole life and just used to that
and then all of a sudden you wake up and
then
now you have a stick shift and you have
to like do this manually it's like oh my
god I had no idea that there were all
these components to this like all these
components to life and whose basic
survival I might have a really good
couple of weeks and be feeling great and
then just the next three weeks just be
sick just like every single day and feel
terrible and also emotional things have
been hard for me to come to terms with
because one of the symptoms is
depression and I battled with depression
all my life and it's hard when you're
you physically feel sick and you
emotionally and mentally feel sick and
just having a support system behind you
guiding you through that because trust
me when you feel like you can't get out
of bed and walk over to the bathroom
because you're in pain like that will
[ __ ] things up in your head and just
making sure you're feeling loved and
supported it's like the most important
thing you need to have self-care I think
the doctor talked to me about it was
probably brought on by it that's
stressful episode in my life that I had
because a lot of stress can do a lot of
damage to your body so I think kind of
getting diagnosed with it it made me
think like self-care is really important
and it's just made me really in tune
with my body that everything works
together like this little glance here
like affects my hair and like sleep and
fatigue and like body pains and things
like that it takes some time to adjust
but you sort of start to just learn and
adapt and figure out like the extra
steps that you need to take first and
foremost like I'm Macy and I love to
travel and I love XYZ and like I'm not
this disease like that's like so far
down and like the list of attributes
that I have I think that like if you can
find the right medicine that works for
you you can live a life just like anyone
else like there's literally nothing in
the whole world that I can't do because
of this disease you get Hashimoto's help
panic actually good that you know that
you have it you can kind of take the
control back and improve your life this
is not a death sentence it it sucks
because you might not know a lot about
what's going on I filled some time with
research I just tried to learn and also
listen to
yourself like I still go out I still
have fun but you like need to know your
limits of what your body is capable of
and talk to people do not have to go
about this alone because you are not
alone there are plenty of chat rooms and
Facebook groups and all sorts of things
where you can meet other people who are
suffering from the same thing
[Music]
[Music]